danny  hey  forgive me what  we're hiding now i went home back to  mummy  [ __ ] you i wasn't going to stay  you good  all right check this  what's a savage it's just some flesh you  say like  you girls ever had a savage this is a  max no it's a sign  says [ __ ] off can't fuss anymore  well it's the truth we're all just  animals  everyone you know that yeah we all think  we're  better and but humans are just another  type of  an animal and deep down  that's all we want just freedom  rooting hey josh yeah  take this take that that's our animal  yeah  our beast yeah because they didn't have  no laws or anything  but society it's already got all its  money  it's houses it's cars and then they make  all these  rules aids put us in one place and put  us in a oh  society do you know what  well thank you we'll take your cars  we'll take your  houses we'll take so much it will just  go beat  be a savage  [Music]  you